shops and pubs shut stadiums
empty streets deserted this our
day-to-day life in 2020
but the prospect of coveted vaccines
offering hope for the new year
but hope does not mean an end to
hardship
still tough times ahead when we come out
of lockdown
next week we must not just
throw away the games we've all made so
today we published our covid winter plan
which sets out a clear strategy to take
the country through to the end
of march a return to a three-tiered
system but with a toughening up of the
two highest bands
gyms shops salons will reopen everywhere
in tiers one and two limited numbers of
spectators will be allowed at sporting
events
but in the higher tiers tight
restrictions on socialising remain
and in tier three pubs and restaurants
will be closed
except for takeaway tighter restrictions
come with more community testing too
through tough tiering and mass
community testing we hope to let people
see a little more of their family and
friends
over christmas the pm trying to manage
expectations
this crisis isn't over when the english
lockdown ends
this is not the moment to let the virus
rip for the sake of
christmas parties tis the seasoning to
be jolly but
it's also the season to be jolly careful
but be hopeful
too i really am assured
now that things will look and feel very
different
uh indeed after easter
a four-month plan but it still needs
sign-off from parliament
and his own benches are in a restive
rather than
festive mood many will hold their
judgment on this until we know which
areas go into which tiers i think if you
go into tier three
you'll struggle to spot much of a
difference from the lockdown
the pm relied on labour votes to lock us
down but he can't take their support for
granted
labour has backed the prime minister on
all the big decisions the government's
had to take to protect public health
ideally i would like to be in a position
to do so again
we will await the detail we want the
prime minister to get this right
he's got a week to do so labour likely
to back the prime minister and he's
going to need it because at least 70
of his own mps don't like the sound of
these restrictions
one little bit they want to reopen
society and the economy not shut it all
back
down but the big takeaway from this
winter covey plan
is that the tears are going to get
tougher and going to last
for longer this is the reality of how
we're all going to have to live
for the next four months until easter
not so long ago the pm hoped for some
normality this christmas
not there yet some hope for spring
beth rigby sky news westminster